bonsoir nous sommes sur un deuxième
machine for pig ces partis nouvelle
partie on commence direct ses parts une
belle partie ça s'était très forte et
très bonne ah bah voilà un bon je vous
résume la thématique combien de voir
finalement il ya eu des espèces des
clercs quelqu'un qui a dit papa on a vu
un espèce de cochons sur son trône de
fer on s'est réveillé puis rendormir on
avait une porte qui s'est claqué puis
réveillé voilà alors c'est parti on est
parti on est y part qu'on commence dans
ce nouvel amnesia où j'ai des frissons
là
j'espère que ça va pas commencer trop
brutalement papa trouve nous j'arrive
mon enfant où es tu
faisais part ou
je ne sais pas par là je me sens bien
papapapa par ici
o'shea de maga au alors
absolument rien apprendre à part un
petit verre de vin poser et on peut
apprendre là on pouvait prendre un truc
me prenez pas pour un con voilà il faut
toujours ça remet toujours
ok le coup classique de la pâte ferme la
porte fermée
mais c'est parce que je me disais voilà
ça le vis à vis à vis un truc sous les
hauts plafonds bomb a écouté on y va
c'est
un méchant arrive oh [ __ ]
non
aeg gère mal fait peur elle est revenue
ici les garçons bon papa que je suis je
fais semblant à mes fils que leurs
blagues sont rigolotes en réalité je
suis pas sûr officier dessus body va
aller je m'accroupir bonjour
c'est pour remplacer la laine duff a put
un homme et venez ici bon de petits
salés gauche du prg et des têtes de
cochon parce que le jeu s'appelle une
machine for pig mais oui mais c'est
évident alors est-ce qu'on peut pas
faire ce type du parcours
non on croit [ __ ] j'y arrive ce week
end à un sale mec derrière m'en allais
qui m'observent un gros pervers mode
ajout promet
allez les enfants ça suffit où êtes vous
haha
sérénité la plus totale sérénité la plus
totale vous n'avez pas eu peur moi non
plus
ok ça ça m'a calmé je vous cache pas je
faisais le malin j'étais là dans la
vidéo aurait eu un meilleur et ça va se
claquait là aussi non n'y a pas de porte
d'accord
bon on va arrêter de fouiller les champs
ça ne sert à rien on s'en bat les
couilles magie et c'est de retrouver ses
enfants
jarry
a même puisqu'à ces bruits stressant et
qui veulent dire qu un espèce de deux
choses étranges pas loin et bon [ __ ]
mais on est donc quoi lasser même pas un
manoir là c'est une ville le truc
bonjour
alors que fais-tu
un homme écrasé de vagues et un joli
paysage allez on s'en va à tous ensemble
plus que moi
ah bah oui mais je t'avais oublier
excuse moi en soit pas jaloux comme ça
alors passer par là non pas voir la
gauche et par la droite
ah oui si on prenait les carabines mec
ok on peut passer ça sert même à ses
serres carrément rien d'essayer on peut
pas sûr et certain alors bonjour
c'est par où je rejoins complètement
c'est je suis en mode grosch
c'est ça qui sonne oui
allô
précieux fruit de cactus aide nous
cherchons la femme à barbe admet
caquetages
ya sûrement des choses là-dedans
absolument pas des gages aux fermes toi
au
laissez moi on allait à une note même
invaincus sont des voisins s'emballe sec
se demande
quel joueur d'amnesia n'a pas juste
fermer la note en n'aurions absolument
rien à faire bon ça me tue de fouiller
voilà voilà voilà au pied on aura plus
d'huile et on meurt c'est ça qui compte
mais c'est peut-être par là en fait
finalement et bien non pas roux et la
sortie au wat
ah j'ai complètement cru entendre la
porte
mais je rêve pas là on se cache sous le
bureau
de mes cheveux qui dépasse je te vois tu
je fais des passes du bureau de l'osce à
on active est une vilaine porte secrète
1 les chevaux ils étaient trompeurs
saloperie de chevaux watts revenais chez
les enfants oui c'est dans un manoir
mois à cet âge-là la gt r je serai à
leur place je me vois là je me juste
compris la grange quoi en fait mourir
alors est-ce que ça peut avoir des
petits enfants flippant pour passer
devant nous l'avons dit
pourquoi on à watts c'est plutôt glauque
cette maison bordel de cochon toujours
cette époque naissante avec l'âge de
raison oui cet empire enrichi prêt à se
faire saigner
de quoi il sert ce levier doit voir un
truc là-bas ah bah oui il ouvert la
porte à ils étaient juste là mes enfants
eh bien non
peut-être vers la bas
je comprends pas là c'est quoi le sens
là de cette histoire vraie dans une
maison qu'il te rend bien à nos enfants
qui s'amusent à notre rôle et est papa
tu cherchais
ils savent pas que le père et plus
froussard que même
bon on notera la présence de deux
petites têtes d'enfants dans les
fenêtres duo
une nouvelle pièce
alors pour courir maintenant comme je
sais comment couilles je joue à mu en
avant
[ __ ] ça j'aime pas
à une note et je déconne on lira jamais
le lot je m'en fiche t'inquiète pas
d'énigme a alors
je pense qu'il faut descendre ben est
partant de toutes les portes sont
fermées de façon pas ici papa viens voir
j'arrive
je repars
montre voix la voix
alors une note est ajouté au journal
gère pour accès rapidement maintenant
d'accord à l'eau claire et des tableaux
une petite fille qui pleure le chat qui
ne pleure pas mais la poupée qui pleure
j
à ils doivent être par là peut être
parler de maître par là
e
7à attendait téléphone y est bien les
gars qu'est ce tu veux
non je ne te connais pas qui êtes vous
où sont mes enfants
ils sont pris au piège tendu sous nos
pieds très loin d'ici la machine et
souliers percée inondées il n'a plus de
cloisons les enfants sont enfermés ils
vont m'aider je vous aiderai délibéré
que puis-je que pour vous
rétablissez le courant ont dû évacuer
l'eau et redémarrer les grands moteurs
je dois être ça la machine à cochons
hello hello hello bref pour moi ça je
téléphone de merde la [ __ ] le
smartphone de l'époque
sacré smartphones avec une paire de
seins bon alors c'est pas ici on y va
bonjour
au mont apic mgr
jean qui est un mec là bas moi je me
casse j'ai peur au revoir je vais
m'asseoir sur ce canapé juste là et
attendre bien sagement à mes enfants à
les
caméras merde allez venez alors on va
ouvrir up
alors viens d'entendre quelqu'un se
faire broyer
toujours fermés l'attend toujours ok bon
on vient juste en temps quelqu'un se
faire broyer quoi oh [ __ ] et si on
lisait les notes
comment nous l'inventaire a documents
découverts alors devant le journal des
russes papa devait plus qu'aux choix que
j'allume mon jeu à cache cache avec ou
quand il veut guerre gronde et
dermatologiques les ags aux musiques
en tous cas on n'aime pas cet endroit
d'accord donc les mecs qu'ils aiment pas
cet endroit mais ils jouent à cache
cache pas il pourrait juste se poser là
et faire du piano pektas d'abris les
mecs aiment pas les trucs pour s'asseoir
race au prix de 16 ha ha ha je suis
chazot fob à
bochum ouhlala ah c'était déjà très vite
l époque finalement peut-être par la non
au et
adghigh d'angelo un hippopotamus mon
copain et si [ __ ] on peut pas me te
monte dessus comme ça serait génial
d'avoir une voiture au bateau teh teh
pas dans l'habitacle des copains à la la
la comme voile sur ce que d'autres ici
plutôt sur kelkoo bon alors j'ai eu des
notes apparemment j
non bon ok anomaux journal au journal
mon journal à désosser la baignoire
moi ça me saoule s'occupe de lire ces
trucs là allez hop a pour à la une porte
parfait voilà
watts [ __ ] mais mes enfants ils sont
chauves quoi déjà stage la [ __ ]
évidemment voilà savait que voilà donc
ça c'est génial ça j'adore je m'assois
sur ce bon j'ai déjà fait toutefois
cette baisse c'est vrai
bonjour
vous auriez pas du sucre pour ma tarte
aux pommes
non par contre vous avez des animaux
empaillés d'accord pardon
cemac et aux [ __ ] c'est le château
quoi à
au
labyrinthe quoi juste le labyrinthe dans
lequel on est c'est un truc de malade et
j'ouvre une porte je ressorte de mètres
après que ne peut pas se défendre avec
un club peuvent donc on veut bien
dommage donc là il ya deux couloirs
hommes et au wat pourquoi pourquoi ils
font des choses compliquées donc la cedh
on est arrivés ok
donc logiquement peut-être par là à une
porte ouverte une porte fermée valu à
alain madelin qui est tombé à l'eau
ah mais ça c'est là on était derrière
des gens d'air qui nous voilà j'en suis
sûr une salle de bains faut faut
rétablir l'eau il ya pas moyen de
rétablir l'eau ici n'ont absolument pas
toujours pas à
enfin se bouger non
mais tout est fermé quoi mais quel genre
de personne ferme tout sa maison que
doit rétablir l'eau le courant et j'ai
pas trop quoi bon y'a rien ici je me
casse
et peut-être une clé cachée en fait
à un visiteur disent
vous ne faites jamais à fizi non ça ne
va plus avoir mérité un bon accord très
bon sterlin dies quand même quoi [ __ ]
à mémère mais y'a pas un truc
à rétablir l'eau là comme ça on va de
gelée par ci et suit les pas rater non
vous regardez une chaise elles sont
partout
ah ah ah
what
d'accord voilà donc quand je vous dis
qu'il ya des gens qui observent les
autres dans leur bain je ne vous mens
même pas
mais bon [ __ ] de ce crime là je sens
un truc comme ça qui est bien dit
scanner à bas voilà à ses deux usines
d'ud trucks quoi l'accord d'antenne si
je me couvre les dents
commencent toujours été leader
oh [ __ ] ce tennis
c'est bon ça en marche ces radars marché
je me trompe non non ça a l'air good ça
a l'air très très bien et bien qu
avons-nous d'autres un ballet allez on
fait une course sur le bas les mailles
potter au génie des
as mais il s'est passé quoi ici la fit
pas
un [ __ ]
donc ça
c'est l'ogre la très bien donc on a fait
notre petit bout du truc est-ce que je
peux pas passer quelque part
bon au moins on a rétabli la machine se
doit de l'électricité je pense
watan.com en fait c'est un abattoir je
pense seulement la voiture s'est
transformé en lieu de décapitation pour
humains nous avons enquêté sur ces
jeunes entreprises qui s'est excusé moi
j'aime bien par aux élèves les émissions
télé alors rien n'a plus rien ici plus
rien ici
waouh c'est quoi sa
boîte yahvé quasimodo dans la maison il
y avait quasimodo dans ma [ __ ] de
maison quand même au delà
des youyous n'est pas un truc je suis un
truc à faire allez on sent bien
aller qui c'est qui gère je sers un
petit verre francs [ __ ] mais j'aime me
semblent toujours voir des gens partout
quoi
peut-être pouvoir repasser par là bas du
coup je suis en train de faire tous les
tableaux comme un vieux gars
donc ça c'est le téléphone de thaler ça
c'est la porte par laquelle on ne peut
pas vraiment adapté que ça a changé non
c'est toujours restricted area ch et
naga alors
peut-être par là
c'est pas la grande salle où il suffit
de cliquer dessus de terrain si c'est ça
je suis sûr que là est un truc à faire
c'est obligé
avec ces animaux est tous là il ya un
truc à faire [ __ ] à je n'ai pas eu
cette porte
ah bah elle n'est pas d'une grande
utilité ma foi
s'il vous plaît les animaux
je peux carrément prendre le truc et le
à voile à ok j'ai peut-être trouver
quelque chose
hu au [ __ ] c'est la première fois dans
un jeu que je m'en sors comme ça quoi
c'est incroyable alors of utah je suis
encore choqué ce que je veux découvrir
au lavage
[ __ ]
pro
allez hop
c'est un petit armand groupe c
une chaise
j'ai horreur des chaises non tout se
remet en place il me semble
j'entends mec qui claquent des dents
mais y'a pas un mec comme il se fout de
ma gueule [ __ ] de chaises dégage non
hors ue killing me
hors ue au mfg killing me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
et ici à sa cheval prendre non ça non
plus ah
mais attends ya forcément un chemin
vérifier comment on trouve le chemin
selon un truc à faire
[ __ ] ça mandat
deva
[ __ ] j'ai cru entendre quelqu'un
quelque temps je me suis gouré
je suis sur [ __ ] je pas fou bon eh
bien écoutez 1 on n'a plus qu'à trouver
d'autres secrets
coucou toi
aussi bon arrêtons les bêtises
oh
mais attendez joue de même plus parler
attendu l'âge il y avait un bruit trop
bizarre [ __ ] mais raffinage devient
fou je deviens complètement fou
peut-être celle ci s'est débloquée au
lavage [ __ ] mais quel genre de
personne fait ça
et ça n'a pas changé ici lui je bois pas
j'ai
bon et bien voilà oh [ __ ] il m'a fait
tellement peur à la fois que
bon et bien voilà je regarde l'heure
quand même eh ben il est vain et ben ça
à faire 20 minutes de vidéo j'aimerais
bien trouver la suite quand même c'est
une bonne chose alors on va essayer de
trouver la suite
la suite s'il vous plaît
écoutez ce bruit s'est répandu qu'on a
touché le grand mère un les pendules
qu'il faut que la nuit tu ne dors pas
voilà à bien je fais trop caca dessus ah
voilà on a trouvé un truc les mains ce
temps son je n'arrête pas de frotter
mais l'auteur ne s'en va pas
fort quand vais-je pourra toucher mes
enfants excellent là et quand vais-je
pouvoir les embrasse avec d'élèves qui
ont donné de tels d'instruction qui
bonne question je la mets ce tiroir
cache quelque chose bouteilles de vin à
mais j'arrive là dedans il se met à
parler là et maintenant il fait plus
rien allez on se recouche aller il y en
a marre bon eh bien écoutez je pense que
c'était déjà pas mal pour un premier
épisode on est des petites frayeurs on
se retrouve dans tous ces épisodes très
bientôt tout le monde puisse à bientôt
la plus moche de la planète
pourquoi les faîtières table
tourisme
là